Do you remember your first crush? What about a long term boyfriend or
girlfriend or even a lifelong friend that you had? What is it about this person
that makes you attracted to them or makes you want to be with them and have
them be a part of your life. What is it that influences our attraction of other
people? Well that's exactly what we're going to talk about in this portion of
the lesson. Relationships, attraction, sexual attraction and mate selection.
Now throughout this course we've talked about humans as social creatures. We
have one feeling that really demonstrates this. And that's attraction.
Psychologists have identified three factors that play a role in attraction. Now
there's situational, physical and psychological factors. So let's go take a
closer look at each of these.